j'ai la à
côé aour c'est très joli
[Musique]
ça ils sont super jolis je vais
m'arrêter là si tu veux pour taper des
trucs d'accord tu veux ou pas continue
continue
continue les greniers sont
[Musique]
magnifiques
le sage le vieux et tout
là-bas c'est vraiment le comme la carte
postale du village les
pou
je m'arrêter parce qu'on a pas trop trop
de
temps regarde le vieux et tout c'est
excellent
ok tu peux
couper
n regarde norm la chèvre dans la maison
ne TR
forous
j'arve comme
ça les
VO
le vieux qui marche est joli
ça ils sont jolie couleur
superbe oh
magnifique
super merci
Fran on dort là ce soir c'est ça ah moi
c'est l'auberge ça c'est ça c'est super
jolie comme jolie comme voilà ça j'adore
ça franchement vaudra le coup de se
poser hein moi je l'ai déjà fait je peux
te dire que tu t'en souviens toute ta
vie ah oua ou toute ta vie tu passes
pour un c'est presque les dieux sont
tombés sur la tête quoi
vraiment l'oiseau de fer l'oiseau de fer
et tout il t'amène voir les greniers et
tout mais c'est unique toute ta vie
c'est énormiss rig les mecs qui savent
que c'est un artiste
Bertrand là ça gage tout il sont pas du
tout VO voilà voilà le belangle comme
c'est bon ça voilà doucement on
profite ça fait que petit plan fixe un
petit peu ouais mais les enfants là
malheureusement on finit celui-là on en
fait un pour faire plaisir et puis faire
en hauteur tu veux qu'on par ouais c'est
ça voilà et puis là on va sortir a si ça
do parce qu'on a plus de
pétrole pe le refaire là en passant en
hauteur voilà ou
top vasy
V vasy vas-y vas-y quand tu veux quand
tu
veux
tour c'est par monter
éidment compenser
j'adore j'adore
ça
ah
merci allez
fix
1 2 3
9 10
11 allez coupe quand tu montes comme
ça petit mouvement de tu fais tourner
ouais le zoom le le le le le un peu de
zoom